[Music]
in poopy pants nude news dude what do
you call that a Freudian slip yes yeah
slip of the dick submitted by name is
verónica light a man trying to pay a
ticket with pennies defecated himself
after being choked by a guard oh [ __ ]
you know who I heard gene LeBell did
that to Steve CC no gene LaBelle's does
judo freakin badass right and Steven
Seagal was telling him choke me out I
could get out of it like go a hundred
percent you like alright you [ __ ] did
it make him made him pass out but he
[ __ ] his past and he went into the
bathroom to clean it
I like watching what's it called what do
you people call that [ __ ] soo
Bushido Bushido I love [ __ ] Oh Jews
[ __ ] martial arts that you know back
in the day like during the 80s and 70s
and when martial arts scare start
getting a lot of hype there wasn't
anybody to really test out to see if
these martial arts were real aside from
like karate competitions which that was
very real you know what I mean but there
was a lot of this like fantasy that was
coming out with it you know like that
death touch like somebody will hit a
pressure point here and then you would
collapse I felt like I was inadequate as
an Asian because I didn't have magical
powers yeah I totally believed the
stereotype that like all of us are
supposed to know martial arts
I did a little bit of martial arts but I
wasn't good at it and then I didn't have
the magical spells like I swear like
Mortal Kombat [ __ ] I thought we would
have those right like kung fu movies I
feel like so cheated like I was like
damn all these Asians got some mutant
powers but what about me I used to watch
those movies and I believed it too but I
was like if they can fly how come I suck
at basketball shouldn't they be dunking
on everybody the [ __ ] is interesting cuz
like even like people like Aikido gets a
lot of like boat like [ __ ] thrown at
them you know what I mean Hapkido yeah
Tito with you know because Steven Seagal
did I mean it's real but then I think
like best when like mixed martial arts
started coming in to see how it's real
up to a certain extent you know so there
you fight somebody who doesn't
no too much then yeah you published
[ __ ] toss their ass all day but let's
say you take that with like I don't know
Mike Tyson Mike Tyson a Division one
wrestler you know like a Gracie black
belt jiu-jitsu I don't I don't think
that's gonna happen
you know yeah well this story is about
Anthony from Michigan he went to go pay
$10 ticket $10 take a parking part you
think that's [ __ ] cheap EDIUS [ __ ]
like here suck it countyman pennies well
the guy just went who's stupid
[ __ ] where's this Michigan wow I
want to live in Michigan just so I could
get parking tickets for 10 bucks don't
you what a deal no I'll just get tickets
on purpose [ __ ] it cuz I would just park
there yeah ten dollar Park is a parking
lot yeah it's a that's cheap here in LA
just Park in the red just park whatever
the [ __ ] you want yeah here's a ten
dollar ticket buddy
that's funny cuz its twenty five dollars
in a parking lot in LA buy discount and
that's why people [ __ ] hate Angelenos
can we go to other states cuz wall oh
shoot it's only a ten dollar ticket
awesome it's my birthday
yes yes thank you guys the pay is $10 a
parking ticket
but then he was told that there would be
a dollar 75 surcharge for him to use his
credit card so he didn't like that he
left came back with rolls of pennies to
pay the $10 went to the [ __ ] okay to
pull that [ __ ] out they were in rolls
yeah oh that's [ __ ] that's already
counted for he just came with ten rolls
that's it they didn't come with like in
the bag yeah I thought it was like
individual payment one two yeah yeah no
II just payrolls and so his attorney is
saying that this is like a symbolic
protest right that wasn't that bad
though I would just sip the pennies yeah
that's actually cool for restaurants too
because you need change yeah
save the trip to the bank so the counter
people they did not accept his pennies
and so I started getting into a sort of
argument with the guard and there's some
CCTV footage that I'll show you
so after their argument he was told to
to leave the building and as he was
leaving that's in the guard and they're
choking on what and we're leaving what
the house
karni the globe in talking [ __ ] I don't
know you still can't choke somebody like
that back turn [ __ ] wait was this a bank
that's some [ __ ] I would do come on oh
it was at the court I wanted to pay his
parking yeah why can't he pain payrolls
like what's wrong with that yeah maybe
they're just like they don't want except
so much change but is it money it
shouldn't it be accepted everywhere like
money well it depends though like you we
see it all the time they're like you
know no bills larger than 20 or whatever
they can set whatever they want but it
might be different if it's government
it's not like a restaurant yeah they
just take money to I don't know all
right let's watch this [ __ ] okay
be strong fishy I wouldn't be offended
if someone like wanted to protest like
there's pennies I'm like you're still
paying me yeah it sounds like you're not
paying me well there's a million dollars
in pennies [ __ ] well thank you for the
million dollars I don't think I would be
like oh my god I'm so offended you know
you proved something today
I'd be like thanks yeah they paid him in
pennies or some [ __ ]
all right here we go the exchange caught
on surveillance you can see seve and the
court officer exchange words oh that's
naughty look at the way he's going into
his court with his back to the officer
the court officer began to choke him in
jail savy is now suing the royal oak
court off the third nice i think the
officer got a little he let it get to
him yeah and they were he was escorting
him like this and then he grabbed him by
his [ __ ] back admit that a rare naked
wonder if like let's say he was walking
him out and he's doing is talking [ __ ]
he would turn it around he goes you wait
till I come back I'm a [ __ ] rape your
wife what if you said that [ __ ] you guys
up on my buddy ed is back around because
of that yeah and also because in that
vestibule there's no cameras and so I
feel like the six well the reporters
kind of insinuated that you know the you
knew there was a black populated
you know if you did one of these where
he turned around and he even if he did
one of those I'd give it to him well cuz
there is that that that millisecond
where there's that pole or you can't see
what happens they're putting in their I
hope he said so or why should I wouldn't
hope but I'm saying like wonder if he
said some crazy I'm gonna shoot this
place up the chokehold is actually
illegal now why he you you can cause
like brain damage or something no
because a lot of people died when the
police do to Chilcote here oh that's why
that's why the whole Rodney King thing
happened is because instead of
chokeholds they decided that batons were
better so then now they're just beating
the [ __ ] out of people with the [ __ ]
with a stick but before that they didn't
use the the batons and they weren't
using the stick that's because they're
not doing the right chokehold they're
suffocating the [ __ ] that's like death
waiting to happen
yeah yeah cuz guys were like on PCP or
whatever so they were too strong and
then they had to like choke him to dead
so dangerous choke him to death like
their bank account one- yeah it took a
good day yeah Anthony was charged with
he [ __ ] [ __ ] himself I think I'd be
way more embarrassed
I know I've never [ __ ] myself from being
choked before I've had two crazy bloody
nose come on like maybe you weren't
choked that hard like passed out choked
maybe he really had to go she was like
you're lucky guys take a [ __ ] right now
ruff it's just conversation later bro
maybe that's exactly what he said yeah
[ __ ] you up I got to [ __ ] yeah Anthony
was charged with assaulting or
obstructing a police officer and
disturbing the peace so he pleaded no
contest to disturbing the peace and the
assault / obstruction charge was dropped
but he still plans on suing the
courthouse I'd be so embarrassed that I
can't even sue the courthouse because I
don't want anyone to be like so you're
telling me that he choked the [ __ ] out
of you literally if you want to put in
those words yes yes yes but I'm not a
[ __ ] I'm not a [ __ ] in that date
having too much pride no money like what
if you get a payout or since I don't
care I I mean like I'll suck dick for
money but I have pride this is different
I've never
and that guy was a geezer - I let a
[ __ ] geezer choke me out choke the
[ __ ] out of me I [ __ ] diarrhea - all
over my pants and I had to sit in a cell
with [ __ ] all my [ __ ] butt cheeks
waiting for my mom to pick me up you
know how bad [ __ ] smells it's pretty bad
I [ __ ] my pants before that [ __ ] smells
because when you take a [ __ ] it's in
water mm-hmm
have you done it without water I've
walked around DTLA where I literally
smelled human [ __ ] you know I've been
around kids where they try to hide it
like did you [ __ ] yourself like no no
like that yeah you did hey listen you
literally smell like [ __ ] be offensive
or anything but you smell like poopy so
he pleaded no contest no no contest for
like obstructing justice cuz he did
whatever he did call the scene he did
cuz I know that um what is it I had a
couple of friends that pleaded no
contest before like they would go into
like those little little miniature
courts because they had like the mini
trials whatever and they're like
typically what does it lawyer friends
would tell them like yeah I just say
that because you don't want to plead
your innocent you don't want cook either
you're guilty because you are guilty but
by staying in the middle you just pay a
fine you don't have to do anything else
so it's just like by him saying that
he's definitely guilty for something
well he said that he pleaded that
because he didn't want it to get any
bigger like you so he just accepted his
fault on that but the other stuff was
[ __ ] well he didn't accept we didn't
know yeah he's still suing I don't know
I was doing for the assault and [ __ ] oh
my friend almost not became my friend
because he [ __ ] his pants
so like you know those church camp
meetings right have you ever did those
were like your whole church gets with
other groups of this area yeah
congregation and then right so I made a
friend and then we were supposed to all
go fishing at the pond so then I went to
go pick him up we were walking few steps
and he starts screaming and he went into
his tent and his parents were like yeah
you gotta go and I thought I did
something wrong and he wouldn't he
wouldn't face me anymore
and then his big brother made him talk
to me and he came over and he was like
yeah I have a problem and I was like
[ __ ] what's going on I tied to something
wrong and he's like I pooped my pants
yesterday and I didn't want to be your
friend because I
what you make fun of me sokeep
preemptively struck your ass yeah so I
thought I did something wrong for like a
few days I was like I thought we were
going fishing dude what the [ __ ] and
then I saw him coming back with his
hands in his pocket and like yeah I
pooped myself I have a problem yeah I
poop a lot and then like oh yeah and his
parents were there too trying to explain
to me and I'm like dude let's go fishing
yeah you wasted all you just had to wipe
your butt and we could have gone fishing
but she yeah he didn't want to be my
friend anymore because he [ __ ] his
embarrassing oh it I think it took a few
days but I do remember the whole meeting
that we had and I was like all this for
what cuz I was like I don't care let's
go yeah and her parents were like I
don't know they wanted a different
response or something like yeah you're
right I wouldn't believe you like what
no I'll just like I don't care that was
I don't care like you know it was weird
I just want to go fishing man you could
use your poop for bait come on in right
my dick a lot but I was keep talking
your dick rub
[Music]